Hello, this is Sonny calling from a very rainy Houston, Texas.
Radiolab is supported by dash digital cash dash allows you to send any amount of
money using a highly secure peer to peer network.
Skip the bank entirely and control your money your way.
Dash is digital cash. For more information,
visit [inaudible] dot org forward slash radio lab.
This is Radiolab. I'm Jad Abu Ron and I'm Robert Krulwich.
Our program today is about music. What it is, how it works,
and what we want to do next is we want to, we want to stay on the subject,
but we're going to explore this a little more deeply.
Take a closer look at the connection between language and music.
We're going to add touch, touch, and that will take us to the ear, the ear,
and then into the brain, the brain, and then to the big question,
the really big question,
why does music or how does music become a feeling?
The feeling, why do we get such deep pleasure or deep pain?
We really have pain coming up to all simply because of air pressing against your
ear. All right, we're first. All right.
Well there is a psychology professor I want you to meet at Stanford who directs
the Center for Infant Studies.
There in front olds is her name and she got it into her head that there is a
kind of deep universal music inside language.
She discovered it actually at a hospital.
The Max Planck Institute in Munich has an obstetrics unit which is very popular
among expectant mothers. These mothers came from the war.
It's if this German hospital and so they were Turkish. They were Greek,
they were Sicilian. They were the so called guest workers in the German society.
Of course, I didn't understand a word of what they spoke.
As soon as they put the baby down and no longer had the physical contact,
bodily contact with a child,
they started to sing almost in one language after another given the babies
Dutch. I heard these, I heard them use these melodies,
Russian gooseneck to reach to reach the child to remain in touch with the baby.
So next day I brought my tape recording
and for an old took her tape recorder from that hospital and traveled all over
the world recording parents as they talked to their very little babies and it
didn't matter whether the parents spoke the romance language or a tone language
everywhere she went below the words,
she heard consistently the same melodies. For example,
I'll start with approval. When a parent wanted to praise a child,
we would ask the parents to show the baby they were happy.
Good boy. Now you got just using their voice. Show him you're happy with that.
I tried that. He get that. I got Hindi. [inaudible],
Kuala Caballo, Portuguese. It would.
These things had in common was that the melody was a kind of a of a rise phone.
Damn. Good girl, Girl. Got It. Yeah.
Good girl sweetie. It doesn't matter what words the parents are saying.
It's always really about this melody
and why that particular melody. All she knows is that it worked.
There's something about this melody that that
keeps the child doing something. There are,
she says other categories that she discovered now with a prohibition.
In contrast,
your goal is to stop the child from doing something in the category that says
stop quite a different melody. It's short, it's sharp in musical terms,
it's Staccato. The back there is the category. Oh look,
pay attention to that. Now this frequently use rising pitch. Look Sweetie,
they frequently use higher pitch corn or Unicorn so far and Fernald has found
four universal melodies that praise, that stop and call attention.
And of course the melody that comforts [inaudible].
And while this may seem obvious to you, if you think about it,
this is music that is understood by infants. We're just new in the world,
but we all know what it means. We all know these songs well.
We're used to thinking of sounds as being about something.
Speeches always about something, but it feels [inaudible] to me.
More like touch. Touch isn't about something.
If you whack me on the arm in a sudden sharp way, I'm going to be startled.
Or a gentle touch has a different effect. And I think, you know,
actually sound is kind of touch at a, at a distance.
I was an old director of the center for infant studies at Stanford.
And when Anne says sound is more like touch map turns out to be literally the
case. This is something I learned from a friend of mine, Jonah Lehrer. Um,
my name's Jonah Lehrer, who at this very moment is working on a book,
an upcoming book on art and science on the connection between art and science.
Do we need it? Do we have a name for that book? Uh,
it's called Proust was a neuroscientist. Okay. Ansys Jonah,
thinking about sound as touch more like touch, I asked him,
how does sound get into or, or touch your brain,
take us on that journey. It's just waves of vibrating air.
Um, it's just your voice shoot and [inaudible]
beginning your voicebox compresses air and that air travel through space and
time into
my ear,
the little tunnel waves of diffuse vibrating air focused and channeled into my
ear drum, which vibrates a few very small bones
and the little bones transmit the vibration into this salty sea where the hairs
are and the hairstyles are fascinating.
The hair cells become active when they are literally bent by way.
[inaudible]
Ben like trees and a breeze
and when these hair cells band charged molecule
cute old blood inwards and activate the shell,
the sound triggers the bones. The bones disturbs the fluid.
The fluid rocks the hair. Yes.
And then the heres set off essentially electricity. Yes. Huh.
That's the language of neurons.
All those changes from waves to bone was to electricity.
All those things were a trip on their way to being heard.
It's only when the electricity finally forms a pattern in your brain.
Only when it's deep inside gaps. When you hear something
[inaudible]
more like touch
sound is kind of touch edit at a distance.
[inaudible]
all right. Now that we have gotten a sound and any sound into our heads,
let me ask you the next really big question. Okay.
Why do some sound and let's make it music. Okay.
Why does music make so many of us so often feel so strongly?
Yeah. Like in terms of what we were just listening to,
like how does all that electricity from the ear going up to the brain in the
next millisecond become a feeling? Yeah. Well,
let me introduce you to someone martyred. Trey, Mo z. We heard from him earlier.
He's a neuroscientist.
I'm in the Department of Neurology and Harvard medical school and mark can at
least begin to answer this question, this feeling question.
He's done something really interesting.
He's able to listen to the electricity as it pools in the ear and shoots up this
big fat nerve to the brain. It's um, it's kind of a, a popping sound.
He can actually listen to that nerve,
to the electricity so faster than I'm able to do here with my fingers.
Is that, is that the sounds, what it sounds like. So how do they get,
how do they get this sound? I actually have no idea.
I guess I sort of tap into the nerve.
This is the sound of sound entering the brain. Yes. This is a sound of sound.
Entering the brain as electricity, little pulses. And as you can hear,
the electricity has a meter,
but mark is discovered is that when the electricity entering your brain is even
and regular. Regular. This is the [inaudible] sweet.
Okay.
Yeah, that's regular.
Right when the meter of the electricity is regular and rhythmic,
it will arrive in our mind and be heard by us as a sound that we generally like,
like this
nice sound that in music is known as a perfect fifth.
The inputs coming from a perfect fifth is very,
very regular. Right?
Good metronome. However, and here's where it gets interesting.
When the meter coming from the ear to the brain is irregular,
jagged a with MC unpredictable [inaudible]. Let me hear it.
This is the [inaudible] which
hello?
Yeah, it is. Yeah.
And what mark has discovered is that when electrical impulses like that travel
from the air to the brain and they will become heard by us,
by our mind as a sound that we generally don't like
like that. Don't care for that one. That's a minor second.
The inputs coming from a minor second.
Okay.
Is Very, very chaotic.
[inaudible].
Okay, so let me just sum up here what I think you're,
you're saying if a sound entering my brain is disorderly and unexpected
electrically speak electrically speaking,
then that would make me feel uncomfortable. Yeah.
And if it comes in in a familiar and orderly way,
that will make me feel comfortable.
There does seem to be a relationship between the kind of electricity as sound
producers and how we feel about that sound.
Wow.
Do they have like fancy names for this? Well that's a minor second.
That thing you just said,
but did the scientist have names for pleasant and unpleasant?
A continent is pleasant. Dissonant is unpleasant. That's not a science name.
That's a music name. Oh, okay. And these are fixed positions in your ear?
Well, meet with me. Be Fixed for scientists. But you know,
maybe let me just propose this to you, that what people find pleasing,
what people find painful is malleable.
I'll tell you why. I'm going to tell you a story now, the true story,
and it involves a musician, ego, Stravinsky,
who is now considered to be one of the great composers of the 20th century.
If not the most important composer of the 20th century.
That's Jonah layer again.
And Jonah tells the story of two concerts one year apart in the same city,
the exact same piece of music. The audience who heard it first,
mme audience or heard it later on her totally different things.
So let's first at Jonah. Well, how does this, um, just set the scene.
This is May, 1913 to spring night. It's a,
it's a balmy summer night. Black Tie costumes.
The women have their fedoras. This was evening clothes. Yeah.
Well this was the Russian ballet. This was high art.
And the program's had, this is a concert about springtime,
but as they settled into their seats,
as it turns out,
that what's driven ski had in mind was not spring like honeybees. No,
the spring Stravinsky had in mind was about change,
about radical change, ritual murder. Literally,
that's what the story of the players, it's,
it's a pagan ritual where the end of the virgin gets massacred.
Oh dear.
[inaudible]. But the music itself is fascinating.
The beginning is this very charming bassoon. It's,
it's a classic Lithuanian Folkston and it does sound like the earth is warming
and that lasts for about a minute.
And then we get some Tutti of flutes and it's lovely.
It's getting a little more disturbing
and then about three minutes into it
[inaudible]
everything changes.
[inaudible] there's, there's, there's just an earthquake.
Stravinsky plays this cord [inaudible]
there's a great story that when Diaghilev,
who's the head of the ballet reus first heard this chord entrance.
He was playing on the piano for him.
He asked Devinsky how long will it go on like that?
And Stravinsky looked at him and said to the end,
and it literally does that chord structures, the music
[inaudible]
it's one of the most difficult sounds you've ever heard.
It is. It is just the stereotype of desinence. It is. [inaudible] it hurts you,
Huh? Well, what happened? Well,
after about three minutes, they ride it
the way they ride it,
meaning what? Like they scream or through they scream. There was blood.
Old Ladies were hitting each other with Keynes. One Lady,
all lady should've gotten hit Stravinsky with a cane.
But once they started screaming,
Stravinsky ran backstage and by some accounts was crying,
Nijinsky was off on the side of the stage screaming to his dancers to keep the
beat. Dude. Wow. Quite the fiasco.
And the question is why?
Well, this is the feeling question.
Why so much feeling about a piece of music that, why did they arrive?
You would think that they rioted because they were hot. They didn't like those
sounds because they did.
They thought those dancers were making strange and odd gestures.
Love Jonah offers a different theory. Well, let me put it this way.
This ride has been talked about and written about for forever,
but to the best of our knowledge,
no one has ever tried to explain what happened that night through the lens of,
um, brain chemistry veering chemistry. Yeah.
What music can do to a brain. You know,
if you try to imagine yourself or all you've heard is Wagner and,
and the great romanticism of 19th century music,
um, and then all of a sudden you get debt.
[inaudible]
these are noises you've never heard before. It's all very new.
But scientists are beginning to figure out what happens in our brain when we
hear noises we've never heard before, especially dissonant noise.
Okay?
We find that chords,
musical chords that are typically judged to be dissonant,
elicit these wild fluctuations in brain activity. This is Yon Fishman.
He is a neuroscientist and he studies those wild fluctuations in the brain on an
area of the brain called the auditory cortex.
Let's zoom in to the auditory cortex for a moment because this is basically
hearing central and when you're listening to music,
there are all kinds of neurons during all kinds of things.
One gang in particular that yarn is interested in.
That's right.
The gang that he suspects gets very agitated when it hears sounds like these
[inaudible].
These neurons might be the new noise department because he thinks their job is
to take every new strange unordered unpredictable noise that comes into the
brain and figure it out. Find the pattern.
There are groups of neurons whose sole job it is.
This is how Jonah puts it to turn that dissonant note, dissect it,
take it apart and try to understand it.
We are pattern searching animals and this is how Yon Fishman puts it.
And so at the level of the auditory Cortex,
the brain has this daunting task of having to be able to disentangle this
complex mixture of sound.
Most of the time those neurons in the auditory cortex succeed
in finding the pattern
that's
[inaudible] not sad, but every so often
this was the case that night they seem
[inaudible].
Okay, so Robert, imagine inside the brains, inside the heads of the,
in the audience listening to the rite of spring that night were all of these
neurons. Yeah,
I can hear them trying to make sense of the new sounds and failing,
not just feeling once or twice, but over and over and over.
The rite of spring keeps being dissonant all the way through so they can never
get any rest. And when those neurons fail repeatedly,
there are consequences. Chemical consequences.
What happens is our neurons scored out a bit of dopamine and what does the
dopamine do? Well, dove mean makes us feel a little dopamine,
makes you feel happy. That's why sex and drugs make you feel euphoric,
but a little too much. [inaudible]
thank you for your turns into literally schizophrenia. Really? Yes.
I don't want to oversimplify a schizophrenia in any way, shape, or form,
but some of our most effective treatments for schizophrenia work by suppressing
dopamine release in the brain. So there's some kind of relationship.
Too much dopamine has been shown clinically to make people feel crazy. Yes.
Maybe that's what happened that night. On May 29th, 1913 music erupted.
Neurons revolted, right? Dopamine flooded through.
This is to their brains and people went mad. Literally, man,
let's go to the second night in our story. The piece does come back to Paris,
right? Yes. How much later after the riot? Uh, it's from May to March.
Actually it was April. So it's almost a year later. Yes.
And this time it doesn't come with a ballet.
This time it's just being performed as a work of music. She'll do.
Does anyone buy tickets? Oh yeah. It's, it's, it's, it's going to sell out.
They do cause a few nights of violent riots.
Can you shut up the situation now the audience, is it a different audience? Uh,
I actually don't know if the audience is different,
but we can at least say that the audience is coming to it with a different set
of information. Exactly. They've, they've been warned
[inaudible]
so for the first time they can actually sit back and really try to pay attention
to the notes by being willing to listen.
They could hear the orders and patterns that Stravinsky had hidden in this work.
They were able to hear the music
and find the orders hidden underneath this noise.
Was there a riot this time? The second round? Oh No. Quite the opposite.
Stravinsky was a hero. They carried them out on their shoulders.
Really? Literally he was, he was literally, he was carried in the shoulders and,
and, and the press was glowing in one year, in one year.
And just one year Stravinsky had gone from villainous monster
to hipster icon
to the extent that police had to escort him from the concert hall to keep them
safe from adoring fans. And that was just the beginning. The,
the third story,
if you wanted to tell a third story would be it became children's music.
It became Disney Music 1940 27 years after Stravinsky had caused a violent and
bloody riot.
He was negotiating with Mickey Mouse over the rights to use his music and
Fantasia, which fantasia is just starting a hippopotamus in a little Tutu. No.
Is that the one? Is it the mushroom stone? Yeah,
I think it's the mushrooms as mushrooms. Actually, we looked it up later.
It was a the part with the dinosaurs. So how does this happen?
How do you go so quickly from being the most outrageous thing that literally
maddens people to a triumph to kids' music?
Yes. I mean the rite of spring is perfect evidence of the brain's astonishing
plasticity. See, this is the really cool part of it for me.
If you remember just one bit of science from this whole thing. Remember this,
those neurons who met earlier, the one that, the little voices,
if it turns out those neurons learn
and they learn fast
because they're actually part of a larger network of brain cells with a very
technical name called the Codigo fugal network.
And what this network does is it's always sort of monitoring,
listening to the sounds that are coming into the brain and tuning those neurons
to better hear those sounds like trying to get the station on the radio just to
getting it just right.
[inaudible]
so our neurons literally adjust.
Literally we're talking than biochemical engineering sense.
So if on that first night you just hear the right as pure noise all the way
through from beginning to end. If you're listening,
if you're letting your cortical fugal network do its job,
it can actually resculpt your brain and let you hear the patterns better as the
symphony evolves.
Is it fair to say that this is a sort of tug of war that an artist comes,
create something that is new and unpredictable and strange and maybe noise ish?
At first hearing and the artist is thrilled to be new in that way.
And then the brain ruins it all slowly but surely by making it familiar and
well, the brain pours the know.
The brain constantly wants to assimilate every experience you've ever had into
every other experience.
And I think Stravinsky realized it was the purpose of the artist to challenge
the brain,
to break the brain out of its conservative cycle.
The astonishing thing to me is here you have an artist like Igor Stravinsky who
comes to town intentionally trying to get people to sit in their seats and
really listened to music.
And the strategy he chooses is instead of pleasing them,
he wants to put them in a little bit of discomfort or real pain even, right?
And indeed they not only listen, they riot, but within a year,
and this is the sad part to me, within a year it's easier to hear.
Suddenly it's pleasant.
Suddenly they like it and suddenly eus driven ski is robbed of newness.
Why is that sad for you? Well, because it kind of, I don't know.
I never thought of the brain as the enemy of the artist before with IA.
But I can give you a different interpretation on this. Who, I mean,
here comes a guy who [inaudible]
offers up the most dissonance, stabbing,
percussive,
painful music to anyone had heard to that point and we learned to love them.
But because of that make you sort of feel like pride.
No, I no, I mean like our brains can decode anything.
We learned to love it only because it's well-made. Yeah.
But just random car hunks. I don't think you could really appreciate that,
but I disagree. Or you think it would be like just having, have you heard
the music that was written after Stravinsky?
It's even worse than what you just did. Yeah,
but my brain has never accommodated that. But some people love that stuff.
And my only point is that if there,
if there are these like fixed poles in our ear between continents and
dissonance,
which is how we started this whole thing and now we end up learning that our
brains can override that to such an astonishing degree.
Well then culture wins, culture beats bile. The two,
but to me it's sad. Sad for the artist. It's not sad for us.
Hmm. [inaudible]
it's sorta like the artists and the brains are that kind of eternal struggle.
[inaudible]
special. Thanks for that story too. Jonah Lira,
who is a irregular radio lab contributor,
and he's the author of the upcoming book,
Proust was a neuroscientist posted down [inaudible].
I'm Jad Abumrad Robert Krulwich and I will continue in a moment.